What I have here is essentially just a big, long list.
And I'm not going to go into all of them, but I will make some,
make some comments that are appropriate to a few of them.
The idea for throwing these at you is that as I said,
the key to software design is having experience.
Experience means being aware of possible solutions, and here's a catalog of
solutions that have been applied in certain circumstances in the past.
In the KWIC quick exercise that you undertook you saw the abstract data type
architectural style as did the, as you did the batch sequential one.
Blackboard architecture is one in which the various components post their
results and their requests on some kind of common data repository, and the other
components look at the repository and see if there's anything they can react to.
The fourth one here, the big ball of mud is not really any architectural style
it's an absence of one.
It usually arises of because of the process of architectural erosion, or because
the team didn't even have an architectural design process in the first place.
We also have already have mentioned client server.
We'll talk about component-based systems later in the, in the course.
This use of the term component is somewhat different than the one we've been
using in this particular lesson, but we'll make that clear when we get to it.
You may not have heard about coroutines.
So I want to ment, take a, take a second to mention that.
With subprograms or
subroutines we mentioned that there's this asymmetric relationship.
There's a caller and a callee.
With coroutines, it's a symmetric relation.
Okay? A can call B and B can call A.
Okay? Moreover, if A calls B for a second time, B continues
from the point that it was last at when it returned from the first call.
These are called coroutines.
A primary example of coroutines.
Think about printing out formatted data.
With printing out formatted data such as with print F,
typically you have a a list of formatting information and a list of data items.
And you, the implementation proceeds by taking a, the first
formating information and the first data item and then connecting them together.
Then getting the second format information information and
the second data item, and there may be some loops involved,
some formatting information may allow for multiple occurrences.
Moreover the data provided maybe in the form of a loop.
So we're really going back and forth between these two streams of information,
and a coroutine is a perfect a perfect style for
dealing with that kind of situation.
If you've got a SQL database and you've got some experience with this,
you know that you can include in
your standard SQL some other functions that you've written.
If you do that sometimes the architectural style is called data centric, you,
that is, you're using stored database procedures.
In this course we won't be getting into domain modeling very much but
there is a architectural style called domain driven design.
And here, by a domain we mean a kind of application program.
So think about, for example, tax processing software.
With tax processing software,
there's certain vocabulary that everybody's familiar with such as deductions.
And there's typical ways of solving problems.
So, if you've ever used your TurboTax or
other tax preparation software, you know if you change something over here,
other things will get changed automatically for you.
That style of data flow updates
is inherently part of the tax preparation software application domain.
And so by organizing your tax appropriation software using this particular
domain architectural style once again you can save yourself effort.
We're going to be looking more extensively at implicit invocation.
And, and also in the Garland and Shaw book that's listed on the resources page
there's a very nice section that talks about all the possible options for
implicit invocation architectural style.
Another very popular one is layered architectures,
in which each layer in the system acts as a virtual machine,
providing capabilities to the layers above it.